there is an incredible video going
around of a a black guy in an elevator
who is
standing next to a couple of
white women of a certain age and he's
not wearing his mask because he's not
brainwashed he's not hypnotized he knows
that
there's more to life than masking
yourself up like a bandito to avoid a
cough and so he's in there and these
women start screaming at him and hitting
him actually all while yelling black
lives matter get out yeah
get out get out what are you guys doing
what are you guys doing
get up
i'm not touching you
hit me
yes you are
get out of here you dirty filthy black
man get out of here with your filthy
dirty germs you cannot be in here with
us clean clean white ladies black lives
matter black lives totally mat i don't
know what sort of accent they have some
european accent i take it
and the guy seems to be getting kind of
a kick at me he's like hey man stop
hitting me what are you i'm not getting
out of the elevator come on i'm just i'm
just trying to get up to my floor
they're like no no these are hitting him
black lives matter how do they do this
how do they resolve this
that they are claiming black lives
matter as they are
literally
attacking a black guy and trying to get
him off of the elevator
it makes perfect sense
under wokeness under political
correctness
under cultural liberalism would you call
it whatever you want
saying the right thing
supplants
doing the right thing
this has always been the case
so
the actions that these women are
engaging in
are
quite
ugly cruel uncharitable
discriminatory even but what they're
saying
is we are good people right that's what
when you say blm these days you're just
saying we are good we are good we're not
bad we're good and so they're saying we
are good people even as they're doing a
very bad thing
that is how woke-ism works this is why
corporations
well they're doing all sorts of bad
things
on labor while they're doing all sorts
of bad things politically while they're
doing all sorts of bad things even on
the environment in some cases they will
say the right thing they'll wave the
rainbow flag they'll post the black
square on blm day and then they think
that gets them off the hook these
hollywood celebrities flying around in
private jets spewing pollution into the
atmosphere
well it's fine they get off the hook for
that because they say
that they're supporting
climate efforts they're climate fighters
they're not climate deniers
all of these rich white celebrities who
live in extremely rich white
neighborhoods and send their kids to
really rich white schools
they say black lives matter and so they
they have no
racial
animus they have no
no race problems
poor white people who are friends with
black people who live in communities
with black people who send their kids to
schools with black people if they don't
say blm if they don't support anarchists
and rioters in the streets well they're
dirty rotten racists
saying the right thing supplants doing
the right thing
now
these these white women i i hate to
discriminate but these white women in
particular can sometimes be guilty of
this fellas i have the perfect gift for
that lovely lady in your life this
valentine's day that would be knives
kamikoto taps into more than 800 years
of traditional techniques from honshu
japan kamikoto also uses steel sourced
only from mills in japan and each blade
is crafted using techniques that have
been honed and perfected by generations
of knife smiths each knife comes in a
beautiful heavy duty ash wood box makes
sure that the knife is stored safely
also makes kamikodo a great gift
i really love these knives sweet little
alisa really loves these knives too when
you can go and present
a really high quality sort of
kitchen utensil like this it can make a
really really wonderful gift i love it
elisa loves it you're gonna love it too
kamikoto is currently having a massive
valentine's day sale and on top of that
sale you can get an additional 50 bucks
off any purchase you make with discount
code knowles click the link below or go
to kamikoto.com knowles and use promo
code noles to save an extra 50 bucks
today
ring the bell
ring but then you'll get the
notifications maybe you won't get the
notifications then you got to go to
apple podcasts
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts
sign up the michael knowles show
leave a five star review
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you